welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition in the 21st century I'm
Parag Khanna author of how to run the
world I'm joined by a very distinguished
panel including tembisa moyo author of
how the west was lost Daniel Altman
author of outrageous fortune and
uninsured hadas author of india calling
well we've all written books about the
future of the global economy and
prognosticated a bit about how it might
look going forward but the first thing
we should ask is to step back and say
who's to blame here how did it really
wind up in this situation well I think
that's a fantastic question um the fact
of the matter is that if you look back
in the last 50 years we really are
fundamentally all to blame governments
for setting inadequate policies
individuals and corporations for
obviously excessive borrowing and
certainly the financial industry for for
approaching these situations through
leverage and increasing the risks across
the globe I think though that we have
said a lot of bad goals for our decision
makers whether they're in government or
in the private sector we've got such a
short term outlook we care about
quarterly earnings we care about
elections every two years how are we
ever going to get people to make the
decisions that will require investments
for the long-term 10 or 20 years down
the road if they're focused on this very
short-term decision-making cycle just a
build on what Dan said if you look at
it's interesting to think about this as
a cultural problem rather than just an
economic problem I mean I'm amazed every
time I turn on CNBC I think the people
who the Carnegie's and Rockefellers who
actually built this country through
corporate energy 100 years ago would be
shocked to turn on CNBC today and see
kind of the reduction of business to
this kind of little video game of
quarterly performing that whether you go
a little bit higher or lower and that
short term is Washington and politics in
almost every sphere of life and very
clearly led to the crisis that we're
talking about we've identified this is a
cultural problem as you just said on
it's also an economic problem and a
political problem I think though we've
come back to this conclusion that we
have a global economic crisis but still
no global political institutions that
can tie it all together and so despite
all of the interests that there is
global
in participating in globalization we
still have tremendous shortcomings in
making that system stable well very
interesting insights and thanks very
much for joining us more on that and
other relevant topics at big think com